hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to iron bread now the
last episode went amazingly well which
by definition means that this episode is
gonna be hell unlike I've ever seen
before in my life but I think I'm ready
for that I think I'm gonna be okay with
that because I am a man of patience and
understanding that doesn't seem like me
oh are those wisps of wind and if so why
oh I don't know oh it's all right I
don't need to give in to panic so soon
just need yeah okay I have no idea where
I'm going if anybody could point me in
the right direction or I could keep
scooting this entire bin along the
sidewalk I'll get to where I need to go
eventually I suppose I'm guessing oh
okay all right
i watch awawa still not work it's you to
be but ok there Hornet at the flower I'm
guessing I need to go towards the flower
oh you can't grab their candy oh oh
eager beaver much oh ok now what the
[ __ ] do I do
why did I do this oh god oh god I've
discovered a secret ha ha uh huh
something oh [ __ ] ah where am I going
ooh Rock hide you are a delightful
do I don't know where I go from here oh
hi Oh No
Oh Oh
they have shovel like leaves why do I
keep doing flip-floppy like that I don't
like doing flip-flop he like that I'm
not gonna make that jump am i huh Neil
bit doesn't no matter how much dirt I
get I guess it's all the same when I'm
toast camera no camera don't betray me
now oh wait oh it's so weird is like
left no don't let oh oh
grab desperately cling to life Oh what
are you doing oh whoa what why why why
why I'm not sensing the ground I swear
I'm not oh [ __ ] out oh god oh god
where am i what am i oh god oh oh my
grip is so gonna run out I have no idea
where I'm going oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh oh
had that been then I lost that I knew
that the last one was too easy for me is
that piece of fence smirking at me you
see that little fence post there with
the smile it is [ __ ] mocking me and I
don't appreciate that oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah baby oh yeah baby oh yeah
oh oh yeah oh yeah baby I am the man
with the plan
and thank you ma'am that's all oh why
why why can't you move like why can't
whoa hey okay all right you don't get
angry at me I'm trying to stand it up
long ways so I can get out of here but
oh wait hey hey whoa attitude in a small
piece of bread okay no not yet you eager
beaver whoa not yet not not whoa
can you just oh my god oh my god oh oh
my god
okay this didn't help any go on I
thought you were falling over then you
were falling ah not yet you eager beaver
ha I don't understand why you're a sack
of [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna need to have a
heart-to-heart with you if you're gonna
behave like that when I make a simple
maneuver as rotate and you're gonna
somehow be like that we're gonna have an
issue here now I need you to decide if
you're gonna behave yourself or be a
sack of [ __ ] okay why are you grabbing
the huffing I'm clearly trying to rotate
you but you're not oh you're gonna have
an attitude about this are you [ __ ]
oh my god yeah I don't like you and you
don't like me but you know we gotta get
through this together
doing great friend whoa whoa whoa whoa
wha
why here are you such a piece of [ __ ]
Wow oh why why oh why oh why oh oh why
why why here why here are you a sack of
[ __ ] I can't even see why because you
got a pinch of of stock in your way ah
okay
so far so goo I'm trying to agree with
you here okay
you just keep changed your mind
oh ok alright ok I don't know what it is
about you being in a potted plant but
you turn into such a raging [ __ ] when
you do know how does that help anybody
know
ok we'll do it this way then if you like
this better that's ok Oh Oh what does
this mean that we're up here oh I love
that we live in Silent Hill do I climb
up this wall should be okay oh uh gentle
like a breeze oh yeah we can make it all
the way over there can't we
wow you're slanting that's a new oh you
sassy no keep going keep going go go
you got no time you got a go buddy you
gotta go that's a buddy all body oh
bloody one good ha ha oh yeah oh yeah oh
you are so I could kiss you grill grill
baby grill I could get down there I can
get down there from the wall oh yeah oh
no love lost on the brick just don't oh
your oh oh your break dancing I like
that you got it oh ok I can get over
there and if I can figure out how to
light it
there's matches on the top of it ok we
have a will we have a way and I don't
know where to go but I'm gonna find out
oh yeah
oh no oh yes that no yes
that's not Oh God we're running out of
time ooh ah ah safety Oh
[Music]
I'm so close don't let me lose don't let
me lose now ho ho I could kiss you
remember I could kiss you you want that
right all right I'm gonna make my jump a
little easier here oh boy oh boy oh boy
I know I don't have to nudge but it
makes me feel safe last job oh yeah oh
yeah I'm adamastor oh not the master but
a pretty good stuff just like that baby
oh just like that oh oh yeah oh oh yeah
oh yeah oh no it's not where I want to
be oh God oh oh no oh no oh
they've got swings one whoa boy whoa ha
okay how the [ __ ] do I do this oh oh
that's how okay so how do i oh how do i
ha ha okay that's also an option
apparently uh I don't I don't know if
that works
Oh God oh I don't know how to deal with
this I think if I push all of it down
it'll oh that's not oh oh no oh no oh no
oh no just fall fall fall fall fall no
oh okay all right this is bizarre and
weird and I'm okay with it oh it's
burning me oh it's burning me oh god oh
god it burns oh [ __ ] okay
ow number one owl and number two [ __ ]
you go that way oh nope
yes no what what I'm gonna fall on you
you better not [ __ ] me over
don't [ __ ] me over I'm just about to be
[ __ ] I am a little unevenly toasted
right now but I'm okay oh I'm okay with
that
cuz so long as you decide not to be a
sack of [ __ ] and fall the other way
oh all right
okay enough goof enough goofing me you
guys I'm I'm thoroughly goofed you can
you can leave the goof äj-- to someone
else later dan okay those can fall out
that's fine I'm fine with that all I
want to do is have some goddamn fun slap
on you get the glue ah get though I
almost have to glue and then it fell out
okay
got the glue why did you do that you
just flipped the other one
ah see just like that just like that
just like that that's all you got do all
you got
oh yeah oh my god are you kidding me
okay
okay so I don't even care if I get on
the grill now I just want to be cooked
that's all I want
I'm a try yeah that's a good toasting
okay it's enough on that quadrant da da
a blammo a little more up blam okay
alright we've been bland enough on that
end that one was okay but I'm okay
cuz there's only one level left if I can
do that one I'm gonna be so happy right
my life is gonna be filled with joy
that's how this works right if you win a
game you don't get a part of your soul
removed you get to have joy in like an
achievement or so
so I'm gonna do that so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]